well that's uh
okay first of all that paints are really
promising and beautiful for some reason
really optimistic picture
that you know our brain is able to
to adjust to so much um
you know so many things happen this year
that you think like how we're ever going
to deal with it
and it's somehow encouraging and
inspiring that like we're going to be
okay well that's right
i actually think so 2020 has been an
awful year
for almost everybody in many ways but
the one silver lining has to do with
brain plasticity which is to say
we've all been on our you know on our
gerbil wheels we've all been in our
routines and
and you know as i mentioned our internal
models are all about
how do you maximally succeed how do you
optimize your operation
in this circumstance where you are right
and then all of a sudden bang 2020 comes
we're completely off our wheels
we're having to create new things all
the time and figure out how to do it
and that is terrific for brain
plasticity because and we know this
because
um there are very large studies on
older people who stay cognitively active
their whole lives
some some fraction of them have
alzheimer's disease physically but
nobody knows that when they're alive
even though their brain is getting
chewed up with the ravages of
alzheimer's
cognitively they're doing just fine why
it's because they're
they're they're challenged all the time
they've got all these new things going
on all this novelty all these
responsibilities chores social life all
these things happening
and as a result they're constantly
building new roadways even as parts
degrade
and and and that's the only good news is
that
we are in a situation where suddenly we
can't just operate like
automata anymore we have to think of
completely new ways to do things
and that's wonderful i don't know
why this question popped into my head
it's quite absurd but
uh are we going to be okay
yeah you say this is the promising
silver lining just from your own because
you've written about
this and thought about this outside of
maybe even the plasticity of the brain
but
just this uh this whole pandemic kind of
changed the way
it knocked us out of this hamster wheel
like that of habit a lot of people had
had to reinvent themselves unfortunately
and i have a lot of friends who either
already or
are going to lose their business you
know it's basically
it it's taking the dreams that people
have had
and said like said this this dream this
particular dream you've had
will no longer be possible you have to
find something new
what are your are we going to be okay
yeah we'll be okay in the sense that i
mean it's going to be a rough time for
many or most people but in the sense
that it is
sometimes useful
to find that what you thought was your
dream was
was not the thing that you're going to
do um
this is obviously the plot in lots of
hollywood movies that someone says i'm
going to do this and then that gets
foiled and they end up doing something
better but this is true in life i mean
in general even though we plan
our lives as best we can it's predicated
on our notion of
okay given everything that's around me
this is what's possible for me next
but it takes 2020 to knock you off that
where you think oh well actually maybe
there's
something i can be doing that's bigger
that's better yeah you know for me one
exciting
thing and i just talked to um grant
sanderson i don't know if you know who
he is it's a three blue one brown
it's a youtube channel he does he's a
if you see it you would recognize it
he's like a really famous
math guy and he's a math educator and he
does these incredible beautiful videos
and now i see sort of at mit folks are
struggling to try to figure out
you know if we do teach remotely how do
we do it effectively
so you have these um world-class
researchers and professors trying to
figure out
how to put content online that teaches
people
and to me a possible future of that is
you know nobel prize winning uh
faculty become youtubers
like like that that to me is so exciting
uh
like what grant said uh which is like
the possibility of creating canonical
videos on the thing you're a world
expert in
uh you know there's so many topics that
just
the world doesn't you know there's
faculty
i mentioned russ cedric there's all
these people in robotics that
are experts in a particular beautiful
field on which there's only just papers
there's no popular book there's no uh
there's no clean canonical video showing
the beauty of a subject
and one possibility is they they try to
create that and uh and share it with the
world
this is this is the beautiful thing this
of course has been happening for a while
already
i mean for example when i go and i give
book talks often what will happen is
some 13 year old will come up to me
afterwards and say something and i'll
say
my god that was so smart like how how
did you know that yeah and they'll say
oh i saw it on a ted talk well
what an amazing opportunity here you got
the the best person in the world on
subject x giving a
15-minute talk as as beautifully
as he or she can and the 13 year old
just grows up with that that's just the
mother's milk right yeah
as opposed to when we grew up you know i
had whatever homeroom teacher i had
and uh you know whatever classmates i
had and and
hopefully that person knew what what he
or she was teaching and
often didn't and you know just made
things up so the the
opportunity now has become extraordinary
to get
the best of the world and the reason
this matters of course is because
obviously
back to plasticity the way that we
the way our brain gets molded is by
absorbing everything from the world
all of the all of the knowledge and the
data and so on that it can get
and then um and then springboarding off
of that
and we're in a very lucky time now
because
we grew up with a lot of just-in-case
learning so you know just in case you
ever need to know these dates in
mongolian history here there
but what kids are growing up with now
like my kids is tons of just in time
learning so as soon as they're curious
about something they ask alex or they
ask google home
they get the answer right there in the
context of the curiosity the reason this
matters is because
for plasticity to happen you need to
carry you need to be curious about
something
and this is something by the way that
the ancient romans had had noted
they had outlined seven different levels
of learning and the highest levels when
you're curious about a topic but
anyway so kids now are getting tons of
just-in-time learning
and as a result they're gonna be so much
smarter than we are
they're just and we can already see that
i mean my boy is eight years old my girl
is five
but i mean the things that he knows are
amazing because it's not just
him having to do the rote memorization
stuff that we did yeah that's
just fascinating what the brain what
young brains look like now because of
all those ted talks
just just loaded in there and there's
there's also
i mean a lot of people write kind of
there's a sense that
our attention span is growing shorter
but
you know it's complicated because um you
know for example
you know most people majority people
it's the 80 plus percent of people
listen to the entirety of these things
two three hours forward podcast
long-form podcasts
or are becoming more and more popular so
like that's that's it's all really
giant complicated mess and the point is
that the brain is able to
adjust to it and somehow like form
a world view within this new
medium of like information that we have
you have like
these short tweets and you have these
three four hour podcasts
and you have netflix movie i mean it's
just it's adjusting to the entirety
and just absorbing it and taking it all
in and then
pops up kovid that forces us all to be
home
and it all just adjusts and and uh and
figures it out yeah yeah it's
fascinating
you